- I'm going to first to
lubricate my articulators.
- [Chris] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You know what that is?
- It's a travel sweet of some kind.
It's a lozenge.
- A travel sweet, that's
certainly a Britishism.
I've never heard that in my life.
(superhero music)
(vocalizing)
- LOL, lots of--
- Love.
- Llamas.
- Legends, lots of legends.
Welcome to--
- Lots of legends.
Welcome to Buzzfeed, lots of legends.
- One little paper, two little answers.
- All right, here we go.
(laughing)
- Would you rather be
stuck on a deserted planet
with Hela or Loki?
Well, you're here, and how
could I possibly not say Loki,
of course.
- Hela.
- Me too.
I guess on a deserted island,
there's only so many things you could eat,
- [Mark] Right.
- But like, I don't wanna dine with Loki.
- Hela.
- 'Cause we'd sort it out eventually.
- She's evil, but then.
- You know what, people change.
- Would you rather get
a deep tissue massage,
- Tissue, I like how he says "tissue."
Tissue?
I hardly know you.
You say massage, or mass-age?
- Mass-age, yeah.
- I like that too.
- Either from the Hulk's bare hands,
or from Thor's hammer?
- It's gonna be the Hulk's
bare hands for me, I think.
- I'd have to agree with you.
And I'm not being biased,
but the idea of Thor's hammer
hammering away at my muscles--
- Chris keeps his hammer in his bathroom.
- That's what I heard.
- So like, that's gross, I
don't want that on my bod.
- Thor's hammer, I mean, how
does that feel in a massage?
Hot stones, but cold metal instead.
We'll try both.
- Would you rather turn
into the Hulk in the middle
of your wedding or in the
middle of your honeymoon
doing you know what?
- I think part of the
Hulk's problem is, I think--
- He can't find anybody
to you know what with,
that's why he's so angry.
- Evocative images,
though, coming from these.
- These are wildly sexual.
- Honeymoon, honeymoon,
honeymoon, honeymoon, sure.
- I think I'm gonna turn into
the Hulk during my honeymoon
in enough time to annul the marriage.
If the person doesn't accept me
for who I am,
- For who you are.
Or who I can become sometimes,
then I want to know right away.
- Would you rather have
Doctor Bruce Banner
as your primary care
physician or Doctor Strange?
- I wouldn't trust anyone
called Doctor Strange.
(mumbles)
Or Doctor Butterfingers.
"Oh, yeesh, you gotta see my
doctor, Doctor Shakyhands."
- That's right, Surgeon
Badcuts, or something.
(chuckles)
- Neither of them are
qualified for the job.
They're not general practitioners.
- Really?
What is, Bruce Banner is a--
- He's a scientist.
- Physicist, or scientist, or something.
- He's a physicist, yeah.
I mean, I'm just gonna go logically,
Doctor Strange knows more about the body
than Doctor Banner.
He was a surgeon.
- Doctor Strange.
- Would you rather Netflix
and Chill with a permanent--
Netflix and Chill.
- Oh, is that you know what?
(giggling)
- With a permanently shrunk ant-man,
or a permanently Hulked-out Hulk?
- I mean, you're not chilling
much with a Hulked-out Hulk,
are you?
- No, you're stressed out the whole time.
He's just an oversized three-year-old.
- He's just trying to smash you.
- Golly, I've got a two-year-old,
and I know exactly what it's like.
- And I've got two three-year-olds.
- Look, it's not a competition.
- Love Paul Rudd, but
I'm gonna take you, bud.
- Sorry Rudd.
(laughing)
- Would you rather have
to say, "Hulk smash"
before you kiss anyone, or
before you can use the bathroom?
I don't know.
- I'd feel more comfortable
whispering "Hulk smash"
to myself as I was
walking into the bathroom.
- I just don't know.
- I wouldn't yell it.
- For me, I think it's
the bathroom choice.
- Yeah.
- Restroom break, boss?
- Yeah, Hulk smash, Hulk smash?
- I'd rather say "Hulk smash"
before I kiss somebody.
- That's really romantic.
- Hulk smash?
- Oh, oh, Hulk smash, okay, okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, oh, quick, quick, quick,
right over there as to the
left and down the hall.
See, he follows through on a scene.
- Would you rather have a human-sized body
with a Hulk-sized head, or Hulk-sized body
with a human-sized head?
- Hulk-sized body with a human head.
Yeah, probably that.
(chuckling)
I would be the Hulk--
- They just described you.
- I'd rather have a Hulk-sized
body with a human-sized head.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- No question, I think you'd
have a human-sized body
with a Hulk-sized head.
- Why?
'Cause you'd be falling down all the time,
it'd be so heavy.
- Oh, those Funko Pop
things that they make of us.
- [Mark] Yeah, those.
- Those things are so cute!
- Yeah.
- Big-ass head, just like--
- That's true.
- I don't know what I'm here for.
- That's true, like a bobble head.
- Would you rather have to
arm wrestle for your life
against Korg or Thor?
Why don't you answer this question, bro?
- Funny that you should ask me, bro.
- But he's got clammy hands,
so I don't want to touch them.
- Clammy hands, where have they been.
- Ew.
- Look at those guns, you.
- No, no, no.
- You'd be fine against anybody right now.
- I've lost arm wrestles
against Thor, repeatedly.
So I know the answer to that
question, for me, it's Korg.
- That's it, we're all out of questions.
- All right, we're getting
kicked off the show.
- Okay, goodbye.
- I've enjoyed this no end.
That's it.
Thank you everybody, thank you guys.
(laughing)
What can we do?
Oh, I think it's under there.
- [Both] Ahh!
- You trickster, you trickster.
(upbeat music)
(whooshing)
(squeaking)